seit sieben jahren entwirft die
münchnerinnen anja württemberger der
handel zwischen 400 und 1600 euro kosten
ihre modelle
die diesjährige kollektion umfasst 26
dirndl die 35-jährige weise also ganz
genau worauf es beim dirndl 2015 ankommt
dieses ganz ganz bunte und glitzernde
ist ein bisschen vorbei und ich habe das
gefühl dass einfach jetzt dass die leute
zurück gehen zu dem was eigentlich
ursprüngliche heimat ist oder was sie
was sie verbindet mit ihrem mit ihm mit
ihrer heimat heimatverbundenheit
bedeutet dieses jahr vor allem schlicht
teil weniger details und kaum muster
heute möchte kundin rascher jerry das
erste der insel ihres lebens kaufen
kannst es vortragen oder im hoch der
stehkragen ist dieses jahr erstmals seit
langer zeit wieder angesagt wenn es wird
weniger haut gezeigt und das tt meer
bedeckt dabei war jahrelang alles in der
dirndl mode erlaubt gälle knallige
farben aufwendige stickereien rüschen
und bänder
möglichst viele details schon
verzierungen schmückten die kleider und
auch die muster waren ausgefallen
zum beispiel nach afrikanischem vorbild
je verrückter desto besser
das ist ausgefallen war die letzte seite
also die letzten jahre war es ja
wirklich himmelschreiend und knallbunt
und china wo man fahrzeugbrand weg ich
ganz extrem
das ist glaube ich jetzt einfach dass
also ein pik und jetzt geht's wieder
runter jetzt wird es wieder normaler
simone egger hat das phänomen wiesen
tracht untersucht das dirndl wie man es
heute kennt es noch gar nicht so alt
sein ursprung liegt der arbeitskleidung
der landmarkt der sogenannten irgend
einen beliebten kleidungsstück wurde es
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts durch
damen aus der stadt die auf dem land
urlaub machten
es muss eine finde schneiderin geben
haben die das einfache arbeit warnt der
mägde und der mädchen am land in so
einem stoff oder blümchen übersetzt hat
und damit dann ferien outfit in grundig
schaffen hat großer unterschied besteht
zwischen dirndl und volkstracht an der
takkt kann man herkunft und sozialen
status erkennen viele trachtenvereine
pflegen dieses historische erbe bis
heute am besten hat sich die tradition
in bayern und österreich gehalten
wohl auch ein grund weshalb viele beim
stichwort tracht an bayerische dirndl
denken
eine übersetzung der historischen tracht
was ist sicherlich damit zu tun hat ist
die silhouette dies bei der trägerin
macht also martin weiten rock die teile
die eng zusammen geht und dann dieses
wieder oberteil und diese silhouette
kann das sicher auch schaffen
für die perfekte silhouette fehlte
materie nur noch die schütze dann ist
das dirndl komplett gefunden
ohne den ganzen schnickschnack ich mag
sehr klassisch und schöne farben die zu
mir passen und ich glaube das ist jetzt
ganz löschen
aber egal welche stürme frau trägt auf
eine sache sollte jede ganz besonders
achten
auf der rechten seite ist es vergeben
auf der linken seite ist es zu haben und
damit ist es unentschlossen hinten wäre
verwittert oder kellnerin
das heißt du machst du schon ganz
richtig und da wird auch darauf geachtet
also das ist schon was wichtiges mit der
richtigen schleife und dem richtigen
deckel steht dem spaß auf dem
oktoberfest jetzt nichts mehr im weg